we're going to do in this video is have
an overview of one of the greatest
empires and really civilizations of not
only the ancient world but of the world
and that is persia
and we see a map here this is the extent
of the persian empire at around 500 bce
under darius the great and in future
videos we'll talk more about
cyrus the great and darius the great and
the various shan shahs king of kings of
the persian empire but you can see it
was a massive empire not only did it
contain modern iran which is really the
heart of the persian empire but much of
the modern middle east including turkey
you have egypt here we go into central
asia and also afghanistan and even parts
of pakistan but before talking more
about how it was established and and who
established it i'm going to dig down a
little bit into the word persia because
just as the ancient greeks did not refer
to where they lived as greece that that
is a
a latin idea of calling it greece that
the the the greeks referred to referred
to where they lived as elas it turns out
that the persians did not refer to where
they live as persia
their terms are actually much closer to
ideas around land of the aryans so
there's based on my research ideas like
ariana vega and iran shah and iran so it
actually turns out that the modern the
name of the country the modern word iran
is probably more appropriate or in some
ways closer
to what the region has always called
itself what the iranians or the the
persians have always called themselves
and called their their where they lived
they referred to themselves as the
aryans or and where they lived as the
aryanam baja or iran or iran shah or
some version of that in the modern
version is iran
now with that said you might say well
why did the greeks call it persia
well the persian empire what we consider
to be the first true persian empire is
the achaemenid empire and we'll talk in
a second why why do we call it even the
chemidid but the accumulated empire
emerges from a region
of
persia i guess we can say that in this
map is referred to as persis but other
names for it are pars and even in modern
iran there is a region called fars which
coincides very close with it
and since the leaders of the persian
empire and especially cyrus the great
emerge from this region they called them
the persians and it was the persian
empire that emerges from this region
what you might want to call pars
fars fars especially comes from arabic
where they don't have the the p sound
but pars or persis or whatever you want
to call it and that's why it was called
the persian empire
now it wasn't the first empire in that
region before the persian empire gets
established or what we associate with
the persian or the key minute empire of
cyrus the great
much of this region of where we call
modern day iran was controlled by the
medians and you can see media is this
region
is this region right over here
and it was cyrus the great that in 549
some accounts say 550 bce is able to
overthrow the median emperor who happens
to be his grandfather and that is the
real dawn of the achaemenid dynasty now
the next question and this was
established let me write this down this
is established by cyrus the great
cyrus the great he was cyrus ii but he
became cyrus the great because he's able
to break out and overthrow the medians
and establish this this massive empire
and the reason why it's called the
accumulated empire not the
cyrid empire is that cyrus claims uh and
to be from the family of the patriarch
achaemenis and a lot of these names
these are come from greek accounts and
so that's why they sound a little bit
more greek but a chemise is a
semi-legendary figure that
we're not sure exactly when he lived but
the best accounts i could see is near
the beginning of the seventh century bce
and cyrus the great is from a keemini's
family and so since they came to power
this
first really persian empire when the
people talk about the persian empire
they're they they don't tend to refer to
the median empire they're really
referring to the accumulated empire
that's why it's called achaemenid
now in future videos we'll talk more
about uh what happened in the achaemenid
empire but you can see the extent
of it was pretty significant and it
lasts for a little over 200 years until
they are conquered by foreigners and the
foreigners that conquer them are the
greeks the philip of macedon's son
alexander the great is able to on some
level unify greece and persia and it's
interesting because a lot of what we
learn about ancient persia it's accounts
from the greeks from folks like
herodotus but during the time of
classical greeks
it was greece was really a bit of a
sideshow it was really this kind of
thorn in the side of persia persia was
really where the power was but as we get
to
as we get to the mid or the end of the
4th century bce persia weakens greece
unifies under philip of macedon and
alexander the great and alexander the
great is able to conquer the persian
empire and he is short-lived we have
videos on alexander the great i
encourage you to watch them his life is
short-lived and his unified empire
short-lived but he has this dream of
mixing the cultures and really being a
unified people but as soon as he dies
his empire splits but the persian
empire for the most part is in the
control of the seleucids and the
seleucid dynasty this is essentially
foreign rule because seleucus who
establishes the solution dynasty he is
one of alexander's generals he's
fundamentally greek and so the rulers
under the seleucid dynasty are greek and
you don't get back to having persian
rule
until 238 bce as in 238 bce that the
parthians
emerge to conquer the empire and so once
again you could say well this is back to
non-foreign rule it's really important
to keep in mind because in its day the
key minute empire was
if not the dominant one of the very
dominant empires of the world at its
peak it had a population and this is
roughly under
darius the great and we'll talk more
about him he was an interesting
character but the accumulated empire at
its peak had
approximately 50 million people
and that's a lot of people
at any time in history but especially at
that time in history because at that
time in history there was only a little
over 100 million people in the world or
at least that's our current estimate so
this is actually the largest proportion
of the world's population
that any empire has ever had in history
as far as we can tell so that gives it
some claim to being maybe the greatest
or one of the greatest empires in world
history and then as we get into the
seleucid and especially the parthian
empire you know in the west we talk a
lot about the glory of the roman empire
but the parthians were
right there beside of them and the they
they kind of went back and forth but
they were side by side the peak of the
parthian empire coincides with the peak
of the roman empire and they gave each
other space and they went back and forth
especially around the middle east
and you have this empire from the
parthians you go to the sasanians and
eventually in the 7th century ce you
have the isla islam comes into the
persian empire and becomes the dominant
religion and so that might make you ask
well what was the dominant religion
before that and the answer there is
zoroastrianism
and it was zoroastrianism
and it was really cyrus the great by
establishing the persian empire
who really spreads zoroastrianism and
zoroastrianism is based on their prophet
zarathustra and when zarathustra lived
is up for some debate it might be as
early as 1500 bce some people say might
be even right before or even
coincident with the life of size the
great so there's some debate on when
zarathustra
lived but it was a monotheistic religion
following
their following the one god of ahura
mazda
ahura
and it was based on these ideas of good
thoughts
lead to good words and good deeds other
big ideas of the persian empire is their
system of governments of governance they
because it was such a vast empire
they delegated the emperor the shah and
shah the king of kings delegated
authority to the regions so each region
each
satrapi
had its governor called a satrap and as
we see over time some of these satraps
got more power than maybe was intended
and then eventually took over but this
was a major empire in the history of the
world they unified people
they're famous for their for the royal
road that connected sardis all the way
all the way to susa as you can imagine
it might it would have facilitated the
transfer of knowledge and the transfer
of trade
under the seleucids you had huge greek
influence but it was a two-way street
not only did the greeks influence the
persians but the persians heavily
influenced the greeks
so with that in the next few videos
we'll go into even more depth on the
persian empire and specifically the
achaemenids